hello everyone and welcome to a most
interesting game a lot of you have
requested it
and for a good reason uh it's from the
uh bukuresh super bet
chess classic that started yesterday
it's a game from round one uh both on
daniel knights vs anish giri
young romanian grandmaster i think he's
20 years old against
you all know anish and it features uh
well one a great move that was not
played in the game but that's where you
guys come in and you guys will try and
figure this out so it's a ten player
classical round robin so it's a
classical tournament uh
not a blitz or rapid or bullet or any of
that i think a normal tournament and
it's the first tournament
uh that's uh part of the 2021 grand
chester
uh in the well you you know what that is
yeah uh last year it was cancelled due
to the due to the covet 19 but now
it resumes and this is the first event
in the series
so we're going to discuss about who's
playing who's not playing but for the
moment let's just enjoy this game
because we always
just show the game when we start
covering uh an event
so uh that's um that's uh opens uh with
d4 i don't know it's pronounced that way
i'm not really a master of pronouncing
romanian names so i i hope it is that
but if it's not
i will cover at least one more game to
to improve upon it
so the five by a niche we have c4 and
now
c6 going for the slop defense we have
knight to c3
knight to f6 and now knight to f3 uh we
have e6 so just closing the the
structure going for the semi-slot
uh and now bishop to g5 so nicely
developing pieces we have h6 and now
bishop to h4 the so-called anti-moscow
gambit
uh and now well g5 is very sharp first
um
now nowadays people play d captures on
c4 first because our
silicon friends uh say we should do it
like that
we have e4 and now only now g5 so bishop
to g3 and b5 black will try and
defend this pawn and there are a lot of
ways
white can counter this the most popular
one is to just continue developing
development with bishop to e2 bishop to
b7 and now queen to c2
yeah and here knight b to d7 is what is
usually played here
kind of continuing development uh you
know that that's how uh
just openings work uh but now we have
knight the h5 by anish now already uh
attacking this bishop here on g4
also might considering something like
knight to f4 then for example if we have
early castles you can bring a knight to
f4
and the white can can't really capture
this beacon then you just get the
the the semi-open g file for for your
attack and here there is
there are a few games that reach this
exact same position more notable one
the one from the 2017 anton korobo had
this against the dingler and
the the game ended in the draw bishop
the e5 was played there attacking the
rook here
but here uh for this game we have rooked
a d1 by that
and it is now already as a movie 11 that
we have a completely new game
so let's see how anisha deals with this
uh new new idea
uh he starts by eliminating this strong
bishop we have knight captures h
captures and not knight to a6
so now it's very unlikely that black
will castle king side white already has
a
nice semi-open file for his rook black
already expanded here
so uh it's uh well it is possible
maybe maybe it'd be easier if black just
castles queen side but
we'll see what happens we have a3 here
and now
bishop to g7 i know some of you are
considering but why not just
attack white here and then white can't
really go anywhere
if you do this it kind of makes sense
because the knight covers this
uh then d5 just uh you know creates too
much problems for
for black because the the queen occupies
the same file as the rook
and now if you if you grab the piece
just for example captures an e6 we
attack the queen and once the queen
moves you can simply play something like
queen captures attack the rook here
once the rook moves 95 and that king is
never
leaving that that square he captures on
f7 is a terrible
threat and if queen captures you can
even play bishop to g4 now attack the
queen once again if the queen moves
bishop d7 check
uh and the the this game will be over
very quickly
so this kind of a move uh sometimes does
make sense but it loses the game on the
spot
so bishop to g7 anish just continues
development we have
e5 now and this e5 move is just
beautiful it
uh completely uh puts the dark square
bishop out of the game and for the
moment you don't really have your light
square bishop
into the game either c5 will be played
at some point that's
uh that's you know definitely going to
happen
but not for for the moment because for
the moment it's defending this b5 pawn
so here queen to e7 uh we have knight to
e4 and of course black castle's queen
side
so what do you do here uh knights to d6
there there was no way
to stop this knight to d6 idea just to
go back a little bit when this e5 was
played
uh white just created this e4 square for
his knight and there there's no good way
uh to counter this it's uh the knight is
coming to d6 where
whether you like it or not so here we
have queen to e7
uh knights the e4 end castles like we
said and now
knight the d6 with check but this is
what anish wanted
uh as here he will give up the rook for
the knight we have captures and queen
captures he was already up upon so now
he's up two pawns
uh for the sacrifice rook and that
knight was worth more than a rook
let's be let's be fair so here a black
does not have any complaints he he's up
to pawns he has the bishop pair if he
can get it to be uh operational then
he should have a great game uh we have
castles by white
and now as uh well black also wants to
create some sort of an attack on the
king side he starts pushing here we have
g4
uh knight the e5 now saying that okay a
nice temporary pawn sacrifice uh black
will accept this with bishop capture
spawn captures and queen captures
uh but now bishop captures on g4 but
this only allows anish to start pushing
here so
h5 we have rook after e1 a nice fishing
suit first getting the rook into the
game
uh queen to f6 and now bishop to f3 and
now
what do you play here well there are a
lot of interesting uh ideas for black
something like knight to c5 maybe
bringing the knight over to d3 is an
idea
but anish starts by pushing right away
he starts with h4 he wants the bus to
open the position and maybe checkmate to
the
uh the white king but now uh white plays
b3 white also wants the same thing as
the king is still kind of
kind of in the center of the board alone
there on c8
and with this bishop and knight
completely out of the game it's not
like uh black has any actual defense
so here we have c captures on b3 you
can't really start grabbing here because
if you start grabbing here then we
capture on c4
and now we could for example play g
captures on f2 check
queen captures and now queen to h4
threatening checkmate and also
threatening to just uh
trade off queens but now you don't care
you can just trade here
captures captures and capture on b5
after c
captures you're going to capture on b7
and then rook here delivers check then
you're going to pick up this pawn then
this spawn
and you're still up the exchange so here
you should win
whether black would be able to hold this
it's hard to say but most likely most
likely not
so instead after b3 uh gear goes b
captures on c3 or rather c captures on
b3
and now comes queen captures and h
captures and g3 so now it's a bit
different
we have f captures and queen to g7 now
going after the
the g3 pawn and now uh that doesn't even
bother with the g4 to prevent this
capture
he just plays queen to d3 he wants to
create some attacking chances here in
the center of the board uh black not
really worried because he can always
just hide his king white it doesn't have
a dark square bishop
but now uh we have a very interesting
move and that is
knight to c7 if you go for a queen
capture son
g3 right away you could play this but
then you we we go into some like queen
d7
check king the b8 queen captures on f7
and although it looks very dangerous
queen h2 check
king f2 we're gonna play queen h4 check
uh we can even play
g3 and after one more check bishop g2
and the white is very happy here
uh let's not forget that white is still
up the exchange and black's pieces
are kind of out of the game uh so here
instead after this queen to d3 we have
knight
to c7 anish trying now to activate his
pieces
but now and also not allowing knight to
d5 to completely block off the queen and
rook so here
queen to d6 and now comes a move that
uh well uh really really uh
puts a lot of problems for for black
so here if you just go knights to d5 the
problem is we can just eliminate it
bishop captures and
now what do you play if pawn captures
you can just play rook the c1 check and
that's it you don't have any more moves
you have to block
and then we're just going to continue
capturing and checkmate the black king
so what you could do here after this
queen to d6 move
is play something like rook to g8 and
this could be uh
what uh what is best for anish but it
will still not be
very easy the idea is just to capture
here and then try and trade off queens
and if g4
then we go queen to f8 we try and trade
and now we go into this
uh well into this line basically what
was planned all along queen captures
rook captures on d6
rook captures and g4 and now we go after
the seventh rank bishop captures king
captures rook d7
and now you play this but now it's uh
it's a little bit better
um than than the other line but it's
still very hard to play you constantly
have to worry about this night about
this
with perfect play probably a draw but
it's hard to say it's a classical game
so most likely
but after queen to d6 anish played c5
here a very active move releasing his
dark square bishop from the
from his imprisonment but this
completely
blunders the game uh so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find
the move that that may or may not have
missed uh while i give you a couple of
seconds here
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
incredible idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show
uh it's uh rook to e5 and this is such a
wonderful move uh because it attacks
this pawn and then we threaten checkmate
but also because it allows queen g3 now
the queen is no longer covering the
g3 pawn but this is what's actually hard
to see because after queen captures and
g3 now we have
rook to h5 now threatening to pick up
the black queen but also the rook here
so here black has nothing better he has
to capture the queen
now we eliminate the rook with check
kink to d7 and now we eliminate
the queen a rook captures king captures
and bishop captures on d7 you are up a
whole rook
and you are winning this game yes black
is up three pawns but a rook should be
able to handle that
uh and another thing after rook to e5
you might try something else you might
try some like let's say bishop captures
an f3
but now we go for our actual threat
which is rook captures on c5 and that's
it
you can play f5 to try and defend this
but it doesn't matter g
captures an f3 and you you've got
nothing uh for example
if you try e5 try and bust open the
position a little bit you can even play
g4 that's how
good white's position is because after f
captures
black will never get the capture here
because we have simple queen a6 check
the knight of course is pinned
once the king moves we're gonna play
rook captures and b5 with
check and now after the knight captures
queen captures with check and after king
to a8 and now we're gonna play rook to
d7
and uh you cannot capture because the
queen falls and if the queen moves then
queen to b7 checkmate
so well this is a lot to take in for a
classical game
uh with with a lot of time on the clock
it is possible to find such things
uh but okay in the game uh he is playing
against a much higher rated opponent so
of course he's not expecting such things
to exist on the board
after queen to d6 he played uh sorry
after c5
he just played a queen to d7 check uh
and
now after uh the the king moves just
bishop captures on b7
king captures and now rook captures an
e6 so now if phone captures the queen
gets eliminated
but now queen captures on g3 and now
comes queen to c6 with check rook the e7
is fine going after the pawn but the
queen is already guarding this guy here
so here queen to c6 check here you add
additional support to your g-pawn
you don't need it at the moment but
still uh king b8 and now queen to d6
uh offering a queen trade uh it's
incredible but
this knight actually serves as a very
nice defensive piece
and uh that doesn't find anything better
here so here we have queen captures
rook captures and now king to b7 so it's
four points against two but
that is up the exchange so here rook f6
going after the pawn
anish defends it and now rook the d7 now
you're just threatening to win the pawn
so b4 black creates a pass pawn here a
capture c captures and king to f2 now
we have a5 now these two pawns are
incredibly dangerous
king to e2 and now rook to g7 and going
after the g2 pawn
we have rook f captures on f7 and now of
course
rook captures on g2 with check and now
you might be thinking
well what about the knight here the
problem is uh white can never
white can never uh move the king out of
check so here king the d1 was played
rogue g wants a king to see two uh we
have uh
rook to e2 rook to g2 with czech king to
b1
and now we have a repetition rook g1
check king b2 rook g2 check king b1
rogue g1 check king to b2 and now rook
g2 check king to b1 and after rook g1
check
he was in this position on 47 that the
players agreed to a draw or rather it
was a draw by a threefold repetition
the problem is if you try and hide your
king for example
let's say king b2 rook g2 check king b3
then we just deliver rook g3 check and
now if you try and hide here you can
even get checkmated the knight is
covering b5
so uh you know uh many a player has lost
uh lost the game this way myself
included
so here if you go king c4 then we can
just deliver this check and we're still
gonna be defending the knight king to d4
doesn't really matter rook c6 and now
it's
it's only black who's pushing for the
win here so there's nothing better after
rook to g1 they agreed to a draw
and even a draw is here a great success
for for that's as he's playing against
uh
uh a 2021 uh you know uh
a candidate uh one of the players that
played in the candidates tournament so
that's
uh a very impressive result missing that
win
uh will be hard on him i imagine but i
mean
no one sees no one sees everything but
yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
a lot of you have requested it so keep
suggesting games uh i i will of course
uh cover uh cover
every nice game from this tournament as
it is a part of the grand chess store
so hopefully there will be there will be
more more nice ones
uh but yeah that's the game once again
hope you guys enjoyed it uh i would like
to thank
tyler melinbacher
expanding your world and anthony botto
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching
and i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the
grand chester first tournament checking
up on your wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent
rest of your day